all right the biden administration has
declared a public health emergency as
monkey pox cases rise now it's a move to
help boost the federal response to the
outbreak it frees up federal funding for
vaccines and other resources to fight
the viral disease nearly 7 thousand
americans have been infected across the
u.s
well here at home 24 cases have been
reported here in clark county today the
southern nevada health district
announced more vaccines have arrived but
there are challenges to getting them
into people's arms one man speaking out
on his experience
monday of this week is when my scabs
finally fell off wesley wallace is
sharing his roller coaster journey today
after he says he contracted monkey pox
during the fourth of july weekend i was
um go i was up celebrating out at the
bars with my friends and everything and
uh if you know anything about
gay subculture when we're at bars and
stuff it's very we have a very um touch
heavy culture you know there's a lot of
hugging a lot of kissing days later
wallace said he noticed blisters around
his body and his mouth his doctor
confirming the viral disease on thursday
the u.s declaring monkey pox a public
health emergency to boost federal aid
and keeping the southern nevada health
district on their toes we received an
additional
2956 monkey box vaccine doses this week
to make available to people who are
currently eligible for the vaccine the
outbreak according to health officials
primarily seen in the gay community
spreading through sexual activity and
close contact with clothing or linen
among the symptoms blisters on the hands
feet and face area it's very scary and i
just don't want the community and i
don't want people to make the same
mistake as we did back in
the 80s with hiv gary costa recently got
his first of two vaccines and hopes
others in his community do the same i
got the
monkey box vaccine in one arm and since
i was there and they had tangled ready
i went ahead and got my covid second
booster more than 700 monkey pox
vaccines have been given out according
to health officials a shot wallace plans
on getting after he recovers i've got
the antibodies now but vaccine couldn't
hurt
well the southern nevada health district
says walk-ins are the best way to get
your monkey pox vaccine right now
because their appointment website is
currently down now if you still have any
questions about monkey pox the lgbtq
center of las vegas is holding a town
hall on august 18th at the center now
that's off maryland parkway and clark
public health experts will be there to
answer all your questions now that
starts at six o'clock and of course we
have a link where you can rsvp on our
website eight newsnow dot com